[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
streaming from
portland why because that's where we
live stream from this
is number 77 in our series of live
streams
i'm here of course with dr heather heing
our seventh palindromic episode
seventh i had not put that together yet
which will not surprise you at all but
now that you say it sure
77 yeah so today
um uh we do not have any ads today
uh we have a few announcements we're
going to talk about where we're going
and then
we'll we'll launch into it um be talking
a little bit about the chauvin verdict
um continue to talk about what's going
on in portland a bit about journalism
um a little a little story on
some new proposed paid leave for
employees that i have not shared with
you but uh you will be
you'll be impressed by the audacity
shocked and amazed maybe
shocked and amazed yes um
uh but but first um and i also want to
begin with just a a small
personal announcement before we before
we move in but first
um tomorrow is the monthly private
uh q a at my patreon please consider
joining us there it's every month to our
q a
um from 11 a.m to 1 p.m pacific and
um we have a lot of fun with them and
uh it's it's a small enough group that
joins us live we leave them up for
anyone who's on the patreon to
to watch later but it's a small enough
group that we can actually monitor the
chat live and interact with it and and
do a little bit of follow-up in a way
that you know we don't even we don't
look at the chat for these
um so uh we encourage you to join us to
join us
there and um i guess uh before we
see you again i believe next week you
will have had
your first patreon conversation of the
month as well next saturday
uh which is the which one is your
saturday conversation
saturday conversation is the coalition
of the reasonable
and how reasonable in fact is that
coalition uh shockingly so
yeah i'm not all that shocked actually
yeah a very non-random sample
of highly reasonable people exactly i
find
almost everyone that we hear from uh and
who is
choosing to engage with us um either in
a position to
support us uh financially or not is um
shockingly reasonable and i guess i'm
less and less shocked by that
as as time goes on i guess it's just the
disconnect between that
and what we are told everyone sounds
like in the rest of the world
yeah it's one of the uh hopeful facts
that
um were we to be able to convey it to
people
that showing up in the world in a
particular way results
in the world anteing up and
delivering interaction after interaction
that is highly reasonable
if people understood what they were
missing and that a small amount of faith
as it were
in treating people well and doing a
thorough analysis and not listening too
much
uh to to the haters results
in uh a a community
emerging that is high quality yeah
people would uh
would be more inclined to behave that
way it's like um
believing that beyond the event horizon
of um
hot fast dopamine hits there's actually
something better
and uh more you know more wonderful
than than the heat and the anger
yeah and in fact it's a little bit like
every
addiction that people have where
something that delivers on the short
term
is blocking them from something much
better on the long term
and the problem is it's just very hard
to look past the immediate
yeah that's right um so
um i lost a friend this week and i'm not
going to name him now and
we're not going to talk about him much
we i may come back
i may come back to this i may speak
about him later he asked that no public
commemorations take place but i am not
certain that i need to honor
those wishes of his because um
i know this will be difficult for for
many people to hear but
um because he took his own life
and a family member of his shared a note
that he had left for me in which he said
that he hoped that i understand
and i don't uh it's it's not that this
came as a complete surprise so i had
talked to him
over the years and i had asked him over
and over again
that if he was thinking this to come to
me um he knew i would not understand and
i don't
i'm heartbroken and i'm also angry
no good comes of such things
and i was then
moved to tears actually when someone
anonymous to me on twitter
said in response to your announcement of
your and gertz podcast
that you and i and douglas murray quote
are significant reasons why i am still
alive after this crazy year
so i am in this week in particular just
particularly
grateful for that sentiment to be coming
to becoming my way
and to feel that we can do good
even while some things um even things
that we desperately want not to be true
are out of our control so i wanted to
share that because i am in a different
mind frame obviously than i normally am
and um
largely brett is going to be um on lead
here today
yes we will uh see how how that goes
given my
certain deficit of uh skills in the area
of um
executive function and leading but
anyway uh yeah it's a terrible turn of
events
um i know that you did our
our friend a tremendous amount of good
obviously in the end
um things went the way they did but uh
um i also will just say if we do decide
to return to this
that um there's a tough point that
i think people miss which is that the
commemorative
ceremonies that follow a death
especially
one like this are really about living
and the living
are more or less
entitled to navigate as makes sense
so while i think it is important to try
to honor people's
wishes uh when they leave the world
those wishes are are not the only thing
that matters
right people exist in in a social
context
and um those of us who go on
uh have to be able to figure out how to
grapple with things and to the extent
that
someone's wishes are an obstacle to that
because
they were very focused on their own
situation
i think you know we have to be careful
but there's a certain amount of license
to to navigate as needed and frankly i
think
in the question of this particular
person who was very thoughtful and
and uh insightful they would also
understand
um were they able to see it clearly yeah
i think so
um and i guess just one more thing in
light of that uh for this episode i have
put
um behind us
for that we're getting instructions from
our producer uh for this episode i've
just put behind us
um one of the boat replicas that he had
given to our younger son
and so that's that's behind us today as
a
as a minor physical commemoration
yeah all right so i think the first
thing we're going to talk about
uh is the chauvin verdict
and i don't want to delve too deeply
into the particulars frankly i think
many people were absolutely glued to
their screens
looking at the details of the trial as
they unfolded and obviously people were
tied up
in uh in many cases in rooting one way
or the other
for a verdict but what i do want to talk
about is the
implications of what happened
um that is to say we have a conviction
on three counts that
followed very short jury deliberation in
which they apparently
asked no questions and
in a wider context that was frankly
bizarre and quite jarring in which uh
maxine waters and the president
um both appeared to urge the jury toward
a particular conclusion and
what i want to highlight is that this
was
exactly the fear that i expressed on
uh joe rogan last year
my concern was that we
obviously have a very dangerous and
volatile
situation where we've had violent riots
in the case
of portland we've had them months on end
on a nightly basis ostensibly tied
to this verdict and or to this situation
and what it reveals
and the problem is
that we obviously had the danger
of renewed violence were the verdict to
have been
not guilty on the other hand we have
a standard in this country of
reasonable doubt we have the burden on
the state to prove
its case and the facts of this case
were highly complex in effect
the state needed to prove that a
reasonable officer knowing what chauvin
knew
would not have acted as chauvin
did they also needed to prove
that george floyd didn't die
from other conditions that just happen
to occur
during the the progress of this
complex arrest and in both cases there
are tremendous reasons
for doubt so
in any case without focusing too much on
the details the question
is this did this jury
conclude what it concluded because of
what was presented in court and because
the arguments were
persuasive where they needed to be or
did it conclude that for other
reasons such as a belief that some
larger
sort of justice required this answer
which frankly in the context of a
sitting president
urging a jury towards uh an apparent
verdict
and a member of congress doing the same
this is
very very frightening and for those who
haven't
thought deeply about it the the issue in
question is this
the founders of the country
created an environment in which the
state had a tremendous burden that it
needed to overcome in court for a reason
because the danger of the state not
meeting such a burden
left the state in an asymmetrically
powerful position so in other words it's
not that the founders weren't aware that
a preponderance of the evidence meaning
the evidence said more this than that
was available because of course that's
what we have in civil trials but in
criminal trials they wanted to hobble
the state and ensure that the state
had to prove something beyond a
reasonable doubt in order to protect
the rest of us from the state now in
this case
we have another factor which is
effectively mobs engaged in
violence demanding an outcome
and we have the state appearing to be
um persuaded by those mobs
such that the executive saw
fit to intervene
in the decision-making process of jurors
so
whether or not chauvin is actually
guilty
he's obviously been convicted so in a
technical sense he is guilty
whether he was actually guilty and it
was proven
beyond a reasonable doubt in court in
this venue
is another question but the hazard of
allowing a situation in which public
violence persuades the state to put its
thumb on the scales
of a trial a criminal trial
the danger of that is impossibly great
and
what is absolutely shocking to me
is that people do not seem to understand
that the the burden of the state to
prove guilt
beyond a reasonable doubt to a jury of
one's peers
that is the thing that protects us
this isn't about chauvin this is about
350 million of us who are protected
from the state's aggression by
that counter-intuitive innovation
and my concern is that we are
uninventing it
i'm sorry i i lost you at the end which
counter-intuitive so i was going to make
a point and i lost your logic at the
very end
sorry about that um my point is the idea
that the state should have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt is
counterintuitive
right one would expect that the state
would just have to prove that your guilt
is more likely than not
well so this this this actually reminds
me of what i was talking about two
episodes ago with regard to type one and
type two errors with regard to
um medical and surgical interventions
for children who declare themselves
trans
right which kind of error do we do we
prefer do we prefer to make false
positives
um and in the case of of of criminal
cases
um it's you know do we do do we prefer
to um falsely convict those who are
innocent
or do we prefer to falsely let off those
who are
actually guilty and what are the
founders of this country decided
is that we absolutely 100 prefer um
to let off some people who are guilty
rather than ever put
um rather than ever put an innocent
person behind bars
yes exactly they did it is before those
terms before those statistical terms
ever existed
um they made quite clear their logic
and the idea was to prevent the tyranny
of the state which they were of course
keenly aware of in light of what they
had experienced
uh with great britain the twist here
is that we now have the danger of the
tyranny of the state under the control
of the mob right and that is a
truly frightening prospect that in
effect what we
to the extent that this was um not the
correct verdict
that there was reasonable doubt on the
basis that for example
um and just to be clear i know you've
said it but when you say
that this verdict may not have been
correct you are not actually saying
anything about whether or not
chauvin was is actually guilty you are
saying that the evidence
provided in the case does not appear to
meet the standard
right and it is almost you may also be
making that other point but that is not
that is not
certainly not trying to make that point
what i'm trying the point i'm trying
to make is that for example we had
evidence in the case
of george floyd having ingested
substantial
uh quantities of drugs that
would have put him in jeopardy in light
of his heart condition they might have
put him in jeopardy
absent a heart condition but he clearly
had a heart condition he had had covid
and was therefore
compromised and he was under he was
being arrested and he was uh clearly
panicking which elevated his heart rate
and so the question of whether or not he
died as a result of what chauvin did
or whether or not he died as a result of
the situation
triggering a heart condition to cause
his heart to fail
is one in which it is hard to imagine
how a jury of reasonable people would
not have had
at least some reasonable doubt about
that question um
so in light of the fact that the
question to be asked
is what other forces were in play right
what other forces were in play and in
fact and one of the forces is blatantly
obvious which is the
the threat of the mob the threat of the
mob or the desire to do
some kind of justice above and beyond
what the jury's
job was who's to say but um the problem
is
you cannot sacrifice an individual
you can't say well chauvin is one man
and uh you know riotous mobs could kill
tens or hundreds we can't do that
calculation we cannot allow ourselves to
do that calculation because
it isn't the 10 or 100 people who might
be injured or killed
in rioting that it's up against it's up
against the protection of the 350
million of us who are
uh who are insulated from governmental
tyranny
by this principle and so you know in
essence as
counter-intuitive as it is that
principle must stand irrespective of the
cost
of doing the right and legal thing
in court um so
you know it was clear this was coming
this is why i said it on joe rogan and i
must say it was one of the most
uncomfortable things i have ever said in
my life
in the um you know in the unfolding
uh emergence of the facts of this case
to say actually
you know as everybody was saying this is
clearly murder and i was saying it's not
so clearly murder this was
complex what you need is a court and i'm
concerned that a court will not be able
to do its job in this case
because of the larger threat of what
will happen if it does
and also what you need as a court
is not a statement that is partisan
it's not a political statement it is a
statement for democracy
regardless of where you stand left right
democrat republican what you need is a
court
in order to make such decisions is
actually what stands between us and
anarchy
uh anarchy and tyranny and in this case
we may have
both conspiring together and you know
yes it is
it is the it is absolutely unpartisan in
fact
the thing that keeps ringing in my ear
is the rawlsian veil of ignorance
right the reason that you protect this
standard even when
it will free some guilty people right
the reason that you protect this
standard
is because of the justifiable fear that
we should
all have of a government that isn't held
to this standard
yeah right and you know you don't know
when it's going to be
on your side versus on uh your enemy
side and so the point is always the
error of these partisan moves isn't it
it's always the error and you know
as we watch the um the educational
apparatus that is supposed to be
upgrading all of our software
come apart and engage in these petty
games i am
in my mind constantly building a list of
things that a proper curriculum
should expose every single person to as
we've been doing for decades
right exactly you know you just built a
list of what should be and one of the
things is rawlsyand veil of ignorance
you know
you need 45 minutes you spell it out the
rosian veil of ignorance just
essentially says you shouldn't make
rules that you wouldn't want to live on
the wrong side of
right you don't want to make a rule that
you shouldn't be happy to face
and so that puts a limit on the kinds of
rules you create and it frankly
sidelines most of this partisan garbage
because
you may get an advantage from doing it
on wednesday and then on
friday you suffer the cost of it and
right we don't want to live in that
world
right we don't want you know to for
example
uh start increasing the number of people
on the court to compensate for what the
last administration
did because the point is then the next
administration will do it to you and
what you'll have is a
you know we're all supreme court
justices now right we're also
right exactly that's the natural end
point of that game
it is it is because in effect it's just
it's a it's a race to the bottom
that all the smart people know you don't
want to trigger right
um so in any case i'm not sure
where to go uh beyond that except to say
that i think everyone who did watch this
trial
if you paid any attention at all you saw
a reasonable doubt
right it doesn't mean that you think
that he wasn't
in the end uh responsible for george
floyd's death though
a reasonable person could imagine easily
that he wasn't that george floyd had a
heart attack as a result
of an elevated heart rate and drugs that
he had uh
taken and that he died under chauvin's
knee
for endogenous reasons rather rather
than exogenous ones
but that isn't the point the jury is
instructed
very specifically that the state must
prove its case
beyond a reasonable doubt and they are
um supposed to
exclude the consequences of saying one
way or the other
whether or not the state met that burden
very good i don't know about that no
i'm not but it's just the way that i
acknowledge that you're finished this
moment it is very good that we have
arrived at this moment something
something like that in this conversation
anyway yep
um okay uh we wanted to talk a little
bit about portland is that right
yes so um i've got a number of
photographs that i want to show but
after um we have a few
videos um short videos uh from our
current mayor ted wheeler here in
portland and i don't know
maybe you introduce that or we can just
launch into the videos
well i mean let's say um ted wheeler has
now been
trending on twitter uh always
interesting when ted wheeler is trending
on twitter
um he's trending on twitter and this
time you know i
always click with some trepidation uh
when
what how do you know right and in this
case i was actually
quite surprised and relieved to find
that in effect what he has
finally said and as you pointed out in a
conversation earlier it's not the first
time he said something like this
but he has said it and then reneged on
it and in this case
maybe maybe he's finally grown aware but
what he's effectively said is that um
portland has a serious problem with
anarchists
that these are uh
law breakers who must be arrested
um and that is something that he has
been very very
timid about and so uh he has extended a
state of emergency through the weekend
and he has instructed the police and i
should point out that it is are we gonna
show the videos or
yeah i think we should i think we should
show the videos um i should point out
that in
portland we have the odd fact of our
mayor
also being our police commissioner um
which means that what he says about what
the police should do carries more weight
than it might in some other city
um so all right zach do you want to uh
show the first
they're not they're not the same video
they're two different videos do you want
to show both of them or do you want just
why not the one that you sent zach okay
so in so hold on just a second zack then
uh in a slightly longer video from uh
coin six which is a local cbs affiliate
i think it's cbs the cbs the one with
the i
yes i honestly i went to their site i
was like i think this is cbs's logo
there's nothing on the site
that says cbs anywhere like they just
assume we know that that crazy scary
looking eye
is cbs anyway that's a different
different topic but
um one of the the newscasters says
with regard to antifa's or the
anarchists i'm not even sure who now is
claiming to be doing these things
um um they keep on making these um
these announcements in advance they're
gonna do these direct actions right
and so the newscaster says in the past
events billed as direct
action have ended with violence and
destruction so that's now showing up on
the news
yep that is now showing up in the news
finally
and now we have this shorter video zach
the one minute
four second one or so and i've extended
the state of emergency through the
weekend
our job is to unmask them
arrest them and prosecute them
i want to personally thank neighbors
family
friends and others who've come forward
with vital evidence
people know who these criminals are they
know what they're up to
if you have any information please
contact the police
acting chief davis will provide
specifics shortly
i also want you to know that these
people often arrive
at their so-called direct actions
in cars and they're all dressed in all
black
if you see this call the police
if you can provide a license plate if
you can do so safely
that information can help later
together we can make a stand
we're doing what we can today i'm also
asking for your help
to make you stand and take our city back
thank you
okay um so let's
first of all i just want to uh address
the elephant in the room as it were
actually that may turn out to be a
better metaphor in this case
than uh than i had anticipated but you
sure it's not donkey
it is the elephant in the room in this
case um so
i do not know whether or not we are
having an impact
on for example ted wheeler's
understanding
of what's going on i do know that this
week i had a piece
in unheard which is a british
publication on what's going on in
portland and of the
absurd fact of local businesses
um putting signage in their window which
you have called
don't hurt me walls um that appear
to attempt to usher vandals on to harm
someone
else all right um a obvious game
theoretic hazard
of the civilian authority not only
uh taking no stand but hobbling the
the police and the enforcement of the
law i do think that there is a strong
chance
we are constantly facing calls that we
um you know admit that the conservatives
are right
that we acknowledge that we are
conservatives or something like this
um and i think this
um we've never done this because we're
not conservatives and
while the conservatives are in many
cases defending principles that are
traditionally liberal in this case where
liberals have abandoned them
the fact of those principles having been
innovated by liberals
is an important part of the story in any
case
i i just want to say we don't know
whether we're having an effect but i
think it is
very important and likely to be having
an effect that people who
are local to portland who are not
interested in
mocking it as a terrible place and
people who are not interested in mocking
liberalism itself are saying hey
actually this is an untenable situation
um and that the f
the fact is the violence itself
has adjusted what people
acknowledge you and i meet people all
the time who say very standard things
about their belief until we say
non-standard things at which point we
get confessions
about what they actually think right
here in portland yeah you're in portland
and so
no doubt mayor wheeler is getting some
of the
same many people show up in our email
and comments and such as well from
portland
right saying thank you for saying for
for saying things that sound like the
conversation's happening within my home
and so the mayor is surely not
getting a proper representation of what
the citizens of his city
actually believe and want because
everybody is so busy saying things
designed to get the mob to move on to
someone else
that you get the wrong idea you get the
idea that portland is much more
supportive of the violence than it
actually
is and so what i'm hoping is that the
ability
that that our position as um
as unapologetic liberals who
uh believe that uh
coddling these violent anarchists is a
terrible terrible mistake and say so
repeatedly
that that is actually finally getting
through and that
in part what may have happened here is
that the mayor may be realizing
that there is more support for him doing
the right thing than he has understood
and while i'm very angry at all of the
violence that has happened
up till now if he has finally understood
this and he's going
uh to stick to enforcing the law
equally against all lawbreakers
then you know thank goodness and maybe
you know maybe we've hit bottom
yeah well it's always a dangerous thing
to imagine
um i don't know if since we can never
hear the videos that play i'm not sure
that it was clear hopefully to those
just listening
that was in fact ted wheeler talking at
a press conference about
um saying specifically that our job is
to unmask them arrest them and prosecute
them which is the strongest words that
he's used
and i took a walk around a northwest
neighborhood
yesterday not the pearl district
adjacent to the pearl district
um although a neighborhood in which
there has been a lot of damage as well
you know to the point that you know some
people are still saying as i understand
it there's you know the damage has been
limited to one square block
like you know well for for a while in
this last summer
um they were certainly focusing on the
the federal building
um but it was never restricted to that
and it certainly expanded its scope
quite a lot to a few regular regular
places in our regular neighborhoods
but my sense yesterday walking around is
that the facade on the street
is now um is now cracking as well that
there were far
fewer don't hurt me walls in in on
businesses
um there you know there's a little bit
of signage still up the occasional
the occasional black lives matter um
sign and such but
um none of these arrays of don't hurt me
walls which have become the norm
which quickly became the norm as of
early last summer
and what i do see is more indications of
fatigue
and questioning and then these outposts
and individual um homes really of
of signage and so i just i took some
photos and we're gonna walk through them
and
talk about them so zach don't put my
screen up just yet until i find
these and okay so you can put my screen
up now zach
um and for those of you who are on
twitter i am
i felt obligated to let paul krugman
have it on twitter yesterday because he
claimed that it was
basically a gop fever dream that
anything was
happening in cities um that was untoward
over the last 10 months um and so as
part of the thread that i wrote in
response to him
yesterday i put a couple of these images
up so some of you will be familiar with
these already so this is just a sticker
on i don't even remember what some
something um
in a neighborhood near downtown portland
says new portland sucks
now this could be i i could imagine the
person who put this up
meant one of two really different things
right they could be part of the sort of
anarchist or
woke or you know any number of
groups over in that space who want you
know more chaos
and less law and order and more
fear among ordinary citizens and such um
or
it could mean um it could be the same
sense that i have you know
we're newcomers to portland we've only
been here for two and a half years
um but uh actually as i said in that
tweet thread yeah
this this new portland does suck and the
new democratic party sucks and this new
national conversation and the new
national culture that are becoming
reified suck and we can all do better
and we all deserve better
um anything you want to add to that um
yeah i mean i i do think
it's these structures and they urge us
on to behavior that
is itself appalling um but
i agree it's not us who sucks it's these
structures you know a corrupt democratic
party that wants to cynically
ride awoke wave for example leaves
those of us uh who you know would
ordinarily
uh find a home in the democratic party
absolutely homeless so
um you know that that is just a simple
fact and i think
increasingly the failure of these
institutions for
several different reasons some of them
economic some of them uh
you know the political corruption and
other such
phenomena that that um
leaves us to erect alternatives right
there really
is only one or maybe two choices you
could recapture these things which turns
out to be very very difficult for
obvious reasons or you could build
around them
um and i agree i've also noticed i
hadn't
i think said anything about it but there
is a
an almost searching for new ways
of um
shaping the conversations there's been a
mind-numbing chorus of
you know black lives matter for example
um and then there has been this sort of
people trying to figure out
how to signal yes i'm in principle
on board with the idea of black lives
matter but i'm not on board with the
idea
of you know violent riots or all
white people are racist or uh any of
those things
um so i don't know maybe you maybe want
to show your your next image
yeah so i mean this this is this speaks
to exactly the searching that you are
you were talking about then increasingly
um
you know the graffiti the tags that
we're seeing um
as of last summer through the winter
through you know the first part of the
spring
really were entirely singled out it was
just this
monotone uh in support
of what turns out to be a divisive
hateful um
series of actions and now we are seeing
things like who are we
right and then however same neighborhood
i happen to walk by a first floor um or
ground floor
apartment with a whole lot of stuff in
the window
so here's here's one of the windows at
some distance
uh with uh for those who are just um
listening rather than watching i'll show
close-ups of three of these
but um several uh several of the signs
that we have become accustomed to plus a
whole lot of
hello kitty figurines which struck me as
something i hadn't
seen before super ominous uh oh i mean
you joke ish but um i have been talking
with
some people elsewhere um behind the
scenes about the
the connections between some of what
we're seeing and some of these
subcultures
um including anime and the rise of some
of this very
very physically disconnected social
constructionist thinking
so i'm not sure there isn't an important
connection here no i
i was only partially being ironic hello
kitty
in some sense i think because it is like
um you know designed to be the opposite
of threatening is actually a very good
cloak
for some other stuff and i've also seen
it uh
used as sheep's clothing more or less
yeah
so here we have a close-up of what are
the one of the things in the window
white apathy
fragility ignorance and silence feeds
into violent systems of oppression
so i'm just showing these i mean this
was interesting because there's
literally a crack in the window in front
of this
and it feels like this kind of you must
this kind of message which for months
and months and months in portland and to
some degree nationwide to some degree
internationally
was the only note that we were allowed
to publicly agree to
if we if we wanted to be accepted and
polite company or something and having
literally the crack in the window in
front of this
um seems
like a hopeful metaphor maybe
here we have this hand-drawn picture of
hello kitty literally saying black lives
matter
and then i don't know what the thing in
the puddle next to hello kitty is but
it's
dream thinking abolish the police so
i i really don't know what's going on
here
another crack in front of it um and then
then this defund the police with a a
cartoon image of a of a pig in military
and police garb
um saying i'm just following orders and
you know there's you know he's crushing
blm protesters underneath his
giant piggy police feet um and it says
a-cap at the bottom all
all cops are bastards so you know this
the same
the same rhetoric right um but again
this is one apartment
that i'm seeing this in so let's just
run through this before we before you
want to riff on these
um next window over same apartment i
think uh we have defund the police
share the bacon um queer power black
power women power
all power to the people and then protect
black trans lives here's a close-up of
that one
um just notable here you know black
trans lives matter we spent some time
talking about what
what the heck is trans doing and black
lives matter all of a sudden
uh last summer but um i believe
and i didn't actually spend as much time
with this as i was hoping to that
there's
literally one trans man on here and the
rest are trans women and that's of
course
consistent with the idea that this um
that a lot of
the um politicking behind
raising the um raising the
the rights and visibility of trans
people is actually specifically
about men who are declaring themselves
women
and very little in the opposite
direction and there's something very
important and deep there and we're not
going to go there right now
defund and demilitarize and dismantle
police
um in case anyone was still confused
about whether or not defund actually
means these other things at least in
some people's heads yes it actually 100
does um again with some weird little
like hello kitty-ish
characters around the outside as if to
make this seem like it's all
sunshine and flowers messaging and
finally
sort of shades of audre lorde here
dismantle our house
build the new um
they do they want to dismantle what
they're viewing as our house
um and they say they want to build the
new but i've literally never heard a
policy proposal to that end i've never
heard even a sentence to that end what
will the new look like
there's the it's you know they're busy
declaring themselves ungovernable
and um and they'll be satisfied with
nothing
there were there were violent protests
the night that biden was elected the
night of the chauvin verdict you know no
outcome will suffice yeah i mean it's
almost as bad as it is that there is not
a single idea on the table
um that is credible it's even worse than
that because what is said
clearly tells us that the people who are
so
confidently telling us what we have to
do to fix civilization
uh either can't or won't think right
so for example um the idea that we
shouldn't call the police
when one teenager is about to stab
another um because
teenagers have been fighting with knives
for you know forever
and i'm not even sure what the
conclusion of that idea is supposed to
be
is is it okay that they've been fighting
with knives is you know
how true is that doesn't any reasonable
situation
prevent teenagers from fighting with i
mean it just
it's nonsense yeah it's nonsense um
but you know let us just say again i'm
worried about
the um the death of the
counter-intuitive
right so we've talked a lot across
heterodox circles about the importance
of nuance
and this is really another facet of that
same
gem which is the things that make the
west
great right to the extent that they're
intuitive they don't require comment and
everybody else has them as well
to the extent that they are
counter-intuitive then
we have to hold not only the thing
itself but the explanation for why
that thing works right and so here you
have a bunch of people
engaging in another
uh counterintuitive right the right to
say anything
right and i would protect their right to
say anything up to the point where
they are calling for you know
the death of andy no or the murder of
police and frankly that reference to
bacon is right
on the border right um but
other than that should they be able to
say defund the police
yeah should they be able to say abolish
dismantle should they be able to say
all white people are racist hell yeah
they should be able to say all that
garbage doesn't make it true
but the point is their right to say that
is
the you know it comes along with our
right to say here's why that's
garbage right here's why that is insane
here's why
if you believe those things you don't
belong anywhere near the levers of power
because you're going to you're going to
wreck the ship that all of us are
depending on
um so in any case you know
the irony is that that uh
the abolish the police movement
is also very interested in dictating
what can and cannot be said
and um to bring this around to where we
started
the really interesting thing they have
been
very effective at policing speech right
not by punishing those who speak right
they're
only a certain amount successful at that
but it's the that for every person who
speaks up and is punished
there are a thousand who self-censor
right
and so this exploration of you know
well okay i am for that but i'm not for
this other stuff you're saying
right this attempt to parse the
distinction between
the um the fraction of the message that
does the heavy lifting and then the
payload
right um that exploration is about
people waking up to the need to figure
out how to say these things and i wish
frankly they were being a hell of a lot
more courageous about it but the fact
that they're doing the exploration at
all
is hopeful and the fact that uh
um mayor wheeler is
recognizing that in fact you know what
they're gonna say shitty things about
him
right but they're gonna say shitty
things about him anyway oh yeah right no
matter
what he he cannot appease the mob who
literally declares themselves and i
i didn't find it but there are a number
of places in the social media feeds of
the
of the self-proclaimed anarchists saying
we are ungovernable and i believe
they were they were marching with those
signs literally the night of
of the night that biden was elected we
are ungut we are the ungovernable we are
ungovernable
um you know burn it all down
why would you try to appease people who
say that
right especially after they spent the
entire summer pretending that the
violence was about trump
right and then the point is some of us
have been saying nobody's pretending it
was about you know
and and about police violence and all it
wasn't just trump of course well i agree
but i mean in portland a lot if it was
you know trump sent in the feds trump's
right right and so the point is cause
and effect were inverted and you know
they're gonna say terrible things about
mayor wheeler no matter what
right we're going to say terrible things
about mayor wheeler to the extent that
mayor wheeler is a terrible mayor to the
extent that he comes around and starts
uh acting in portland's interest we'll
say you know what
we're pissed off about what went before
but thank goodness we're headed in the
right direction
like we always say to our children it's
about the future man it's about that
it's about the future
can we get it right from now on it's
about the future and so what did you
learn
[Laughter]
yeah so um so this is this is
interesting i should say
in passing um we have invited mayor
wheeler on the program
before um have we have you i believe i
have
if i haven't it's an oversight i meant
to but i believe i have
um i would i'm going to uh invite him
again
if he would like to talk about what is
in the interest of portland what is
the future of liberalism any of these
things that would be wonderful
i think it would be great to have him i
would also say
to paul krugman uh
what you tweeted yesterday which heather
rightly took you to task
she was not alone in doing so but
rightly took you to task for indicates
that you have completely lost sight of
what is actually taking place
in certain parts of the country like for
example portland where yes
actually violent mobs have taken to
actually damaging the city and
threatening
citizens regularly i mean
it's evidence of either a willful
blindness
or or lying or again a kind of this
innumeracy which for god's sake and
nobel laureate in economics should not
be guilty of but like
i took a run and i didn't nothing bad
happened to me
therefore nothing bad happens in that
part of the city ever
sort of sort of logic and i don't know
if he took any runs whatever but i've
seen that kind of logic from other
journalists like well i was out in that
place that they say is dangerous
and nothing happened like that's that's
the same it's the same a logic as mostly
peaceful
it is on the other hand i mean first of
all
this one is so easy to falsify and
krugman ended up looking so dumb
for having said this that i don't think
it could be anything it's it's not in
numeracy
right it can't be a numeracy um it can't
be lying because it would be so stupid
to engage in this kind of lying it has
to be
look dude your filter bubble is actually
preventing you from
actually knowing what's going on and
it's at a level that is dangerous
no i think i think there's an adjacent
hypothesis which is going to sound very
similar but it's actually different
your filter bubble is preventing you
from voicing
what is going on and maybe it's
preventing you from seeing it
but even if you can see it you shalt not
say it and so there are some number of
people
in that filter bubble that krugman
presumably shares with you know a whole
lot of other big name
powerful journalists and thinkers and
all who actually
can begin to see can see what is going
on
but they will be ostracized they will be
shunned
um if you know if if they say it and you
know we see the same kind of filter
bubble and
um you know it's the gated institutional
narrative that that your your brother
so named the gin um over
in um you know origins of covet
space and in actually
uh the trans rights activists are not
speaking for most trans people
space and you know a lot of these things
were you know
a number of us are like actually no and
sorry you can't fire me i don't work for
you
right and but a lot of people you know
have jobs have employers and
don't feel like they can say anything so
that's you know the vast majority of
americans
and really it's incumbent on people like
krugman
and the other the other trend setters
who do kind of ish have employers but
actually could say anything that they
need to that they feel is true
to look outside the damn filter bubble
and to say what is true
and to never make these claims that are
so easily falsifiable my god
all right so uh you know i i agree that
there
there are at least two uh adjacent
explanations in here and that the the
right explanation is liable to be
somewhere in this neighborhood
um i do think surely
paul krugman discovered something in
him having tweeted what he did he
tweeted that
conservatives are all under the false
impression
that violent mobs have been damaging
major cities and this happens to have
happened without the notice of the
people who live in those cities
so paul you [ __ ] up
we live in portland it has happened here
we have been
absolutely steadfast and careful in not
exaggerating what has happened here
the uh violence has been relentless but
it has
been concentrated on narrow parts of the
city so there is
regular violence it is not the city as a
whole on fire
anything like that but it has happened
we have noticed
although it's also true that homicides
and fatal car crashes are way up this
year and that's less concentrated
and you know is that is who exactly is
to blame
well the move that has been somewhat
successful to defund the police and to
defund particular branches of policing
are in part are in part to blame for
that
and the reason that the city council was
able to move forward
uh with that move was largely because of
mob's support
for an anarchic branch of blm
absolutely um i should point out that uh
paul can also look up the fact that
antifa broke into the mayor's own
building and lit a fire in his
lobby despite the fact that there were
families inhabiting the building
upstairs this is not this is not fiction
it's not
symbolic it's not hard to find if you
look for it
so two things i would say one
paul you should come on the program and
you should talk to us it's the right
thing to do having discovered that
somehow
whatever it is that you're doing to
source information on how things are
going
in places like portland has uh somehow
caused you to miss
the salient pieces of information and uh
you'll get a fair shake
if you come on darkhorse i would also uh
suggest actually the the more i think
about it i would like people if they
haven't encountered
uh the piece that i wrote for unheard to
check it out we will link it in the
description here
and it discusses a number of things
including the predicament
of those of us citizens who would like a
functional
city in which we didn't feel like we had
to be armed
but have had to reluctantly purchase
arms because it was clear
that we couldn't rely on the protection
of the police
with the mayor's office hobbling them
and i would say that that piece also
ends on on an important note about what
could be true of a place like portland
if it decided to make uh to not make the
same mistakes as
la and new york and seattle and these
other cities or just i mean really
and we've talked about this before but
um the west coast has suffered
very similar fate the big west coast
cities have
have suffered similar fates due to
frankly
similar ideological underpinnings
becoming dominant in those cities
san diego last so san diego is a bit of
an outlier here
but la san francisco seattle why when
looking
at those those other major cities on the
west coast would you say
you know okay yeah portland let's try
the same and you know we're clearly
there portland is smaller and it's
less far along in terms of its economic
development
and why wouldn't we aspire to be the
shining jewel
um that you know that seattle and san
francisco and la have been in parts i
don't you know i don't know what all we
could
we could be amazing at but it is a
beautiful city with an extraordinary
populace and um we're just we're
encouraging a tiny
band of anarchists to just set the
narrative yeah who are
destroying the tax base and will
therefore mean that the city will be
hobbled in doing
uh what it needs to do for its citizens
and frankly all of the oppressed people
that
liberals of this stripe have
given so much lip service would be
better served by actually governing the
city
in a way that it was economically
vibrant
so in any case you should check out that
that article
it uh it deals with this and it deals
with a very uncomfortable question
of whether or not what has happened in
la san francisco
seattle and portland is that the tension
that makes things so good the tension
where liberals try to solve problems and
conservatives hold their feet to the
fire and
uh focus on the potential unintended
consequences
that has failed and it is the unopposed
and therefore uninvestigated kind of
liberalism that we're seeing
that is the hazard which you know you're
hearing this from liberals this is not
an indictment of the idea of progress
this is a recognition
that um you need people to hold your
feet to the fire
or terrible ideas end up as policy yeah
and you know it is a truism in modern
american politics that cities trend blue
and the rural areas trend red but um you
know new york i think is going to look
different from the west coast cities
because um because it is more diverse
politically
that the east coast and the major cities
in the middle of the country and on the
on the gulf coast
or near in the south um are
more politically diverse there is more
pushback and the west coast
um has a kind of homogeneity a lack of
diversity actually
um in its ideological underpinnings um
that meant that as this thing started to
ascend
there were very few people in any
position of power who actually were on
the right
um or those of us on the left who you
know maybe took a little longer to see
it than people on the right would have
because it
came shrouded in stuff that sounded like
it was coming from the left
uh to say now hold on a minute you know
you're that's that is not gonna end well
yeah yeah absolutely um
well in any case we'll see where this
goes i mean it could go a lot of places
um i certainly did not expect to see
mayor wheeler take a stand yesterday so
maybe that's a hopeful sign and
hopefully he'll he'll stick to it and
take us up on our offer to come visit
darkhorse yeah that would be great
um here's just a note about
state of journalism um
this is from last sunday's new york
times the very top of the sunday review
which is
you know to my reading we still get this
[Laughter]
we still get this hard copy of the
sunday new york times
um and i always take crap from people
when i admit that um and you you have no
responsibility well we get it for
uh exercise we don't have birds what we
don't have
no no no exercise exercise yes rolling
our eyes
nice and crossing our teeth
wow sure um so this is sunday what even
does that say actually i have a hard
copy here see i actually do have it
sunday april 18th
the very top of the sunday review it
says
with a quote that's actually
unattributed like i presume it's in this
front this article that is titled
minnesota
comma america um but the quote at the
very top without attribution
is my great grandparents joined in the
great migration to land in minneapolis
and over the years we've all seen how
neighbors choose to ignore the suffering
of those who don't look like them
so i didn't go to journalism school
you know i was i was in journalism in
high school
right i don't really know what it is
that journalists are supposed to be
doing like by
by the book or actually have thought
deeply about exactly what their job is
supposed to be but
i know that the best journalism that
i've seen
goes and collects individual stories
from people
as a way to either
build a story or to add color to a story
that they've already got
and then either uses those stories to
build an analysis
or better goes and finds analysis that
other people have done
and uses the stories to basically tie
together the analysis
in this quote what we have is an
individual presumably this sounds like
some
some rando living in minneapolis right
um who a journalist has gone and stuck a
mic in their face
been like to what do you attribute the
causes of societal ills
and i mean just just look at there's a
no personal story here except my
great-grandparents joined in the great
migration so it
sounds like this is a lived experience
sort of story and lived experience as
much as it's taken a lot of flack lately
cannot be the basis for an underpinning
of an understanding of reality
but it is what all of us know so it's
not that it's
it's a flawed way of understanding the
world unless you take it as the only way
of understanding the world so
here's the beginning of of a story but
then
and over the years we've all seen how
neighbors
choose to ignore the suffering of those
who don't look like them
that's that is a claim right that
requires
substantial evidence and
frankly i was um i think in the wake of
the
chauvin verdict um gavin newsom
i believe i hope i get this right
tweeted that there's no way
what happened to him would have happened
to um that would have what happened to
floyd would have happened to newsome
because of his white skin
and um our friend camille foster is like
i know enough about this case no that's
not true dude
like no no and no like
as much as this verdict has um you know
you talked about a lot of the things
that are true about that verdict
there is nothing in that has to do with
with race
well there is a style of thinking
yeah that explains the kind of
journalism you're talking about explains
uh governor newsom's um
odd statement that's the governor of
california and so much of the rest of
this which is
i have a position for some reason i take
it as essentially
god-given right it is the right position
vaccines are safe for example
therefore everything that points in that
direction is true and everything that
points in the other direction is false
right and you know it's like the last
brand loyalty for ideology
yes it but it's it's the logic of a
third grader
right it's the logic of a third grader
that just feels entitled to the facts
and um you know the world would be
shaped around these simple
uh distinctions that the person is
drawing and the frightening thing
is that we are being governed by people
who now increasingly think this way and
i don't think that they
inherently think this way i don't think
these you know i mean it's amazing how
many people
we know in the heterodoxy world have
some version
of smart yet idiot which i think is
uh um is uh naseem to leb's version of
it
um that's his phrasing right and the
point is i'm not
saying they don't have mental horsepower
to think i'm just saying they say stupid
[ __ ] all the time
and that is an indictment of whatever it
is that they're doing instead of
thinking right
um so the we are
living in a world between uh you know
governmental authorities and journalists
and university professors and um
tech moguls where all of these people
seem to feel that they are entitled to
be
right and that anything that points in
another direction is inherently cheating
and that they have the right to silence
it or
chastise it or whatever it is that they
do and the point is
look that can't work
that's like setting a really good
course and then putting on blinders and
imagining you're going to end up
where you go you've got to be able to
deal dynamically with the discovery that
you were slightly off or that the wind
put you see
somewhere where you didn't you didn't
know that you were and this is
just this is madness this is not how we
can govern ourselves this is the recipe
for taking
everything that works and wrecking it
yeah yes
okay um
you haven't seen this um
this announcement hold on zach um
was made on twitter boy i guess that's
april 23rd that's yesterday and it
already has
186 000 likes wow that sounds very
likeable
yeah so likable so zach you can just
show it very briefly then give me my
screen back
what's up
uh this i don't know how to pronounce
her name gloria dlamini
liebenberg says my husband and i have
introduced paid menstrually for our
female employees
this makes me so happy as a woman
so some women experience debilitating
menstrual cramps and do indeed find it
difficult to work for some days
each month and
those women i i know i've known some of
them
um do find it um unnerving to
have to request sick days especially on
those on those days
um it's not all women i i really don't
think it's a majority of women and in
fact at a different moment perhaps
uh we can talk about actually what
um what menstruation and all of you know
all of the things associated with it
um mean in light of our post-industrial
context and what it actually looks like
in
in pre-industrial contexts and what
therefore we might be doing to alleviate
um a lot of this um pain and agony for
so many
for so many women who live in the weird
world western
educated industrialized rich democratic
countries
um so it's it's not even close to a
majority of women even in the weird
world
um furthermore most women um
i believe would prefer privacy to having
a a monthly leave in which
their absence is therefore understood by
their employer and all of their
colleagues to be
about this being that time of the month
for them this smacks to me of menstrual
heights
[Music]
of for instance the hadza in uh i think
it's west africa
um and a few other hunter-gatherer
cultures in which um
uh women are effectively ostracized um
while they are um while they're
menstruating and it's a way of publicly
marking them
in terms of where they are in their
cycles which is a way for men to control
um fertility of women and obviously
that's not the
the motivation here it's not the
motivation isn't to control the
fertility of female workers but
um uh it does it feels exactly like that
to me um and um
and you know it'll allow people who are
keeping track to know when
a woman is late maybe when she's
entering menopause when things get
less regular this seems a little less
than desirable for an employer and all
the colleagues to know
so you know if this had emerged from a
conservative obviously this would be
this would be laughable right it'd be
just
insane justly ridiculed it would have
been incredible outrage you're gonna do
what now um but um
i think also you know maybe the way to
approach this um as a way to make it
clear that this is just a terrible
policy and you know
and it can't last like it's just it's no
no company that's doing this is
any company that does this the women are
going to start costing more
and then they're going to start hiring
men more because the women cost
more and then there's going to be
complaints that they aren't hiring
enough women and you know
it's just you know down this road
nothing good will come
um but you know we do have
and i think it's it's necessary that we
have things like pregnancy leave and
there are
real barriers to uh female success
in career tracks that require you know
hard paced
hard charging work exactly during your
reproductive years
during which time pregnancy and early
motherhood
may render you less able or less willing
to be hard charging in the same way and
so at least in academia the world that
we know the best
there have been some moves to for
instance stop the tenure clock for
a year or two such that um you know your
public your publication record
during the time when you were um perhaps
um
perhaps having a kid um does not count
against you in the same way that it
would it's not a perfect solution but
it's
you can't you can't make it the same
right men and women are not
the same and this is you know this is
this will always be a problem there is
no easy solution but i was just thinking
that
um if if time off for for menstruation
is to be a thing given that women
menstruate and men don't yeah you heard
it here first that's
that's actually true um in the name of
equity i think then following this
business is lead it's also true across
cultures across time that men have
shorter life spans than women
and therefore we should mandate earlier
retirement for men to allow for the same
average period of lifespan that's post
post-work
um so in order to provide equitable
post-retirement work oh this is such a
dangerous
line of thinking because of course that
limits male earning potential so you
would have to pay them more
to earn the same amount that's true in a
shorter period of time given that our
lives are accelerated um yeah this is
really terrible stuff
it's awful it's it's ridiculous yeah
it's preposterous and
you know it's another wonderful uh
demonstration of
the need for rawlsy and veil of
ignorance
thinking because uh of course if
you know as you uh suggest in here as
you hint at
if it is true that women deserve time
off
uh for um menstrual symptoms and there's
no different
difference between men and women than
men also do
right so the point is you can just see
how if you begin to play with these
conclusions well the real point is
here are some people we would like to
give an advantage to and here's some
logic we cobbled together to explain why
they get the advantage
but the problem is it's lego and you
could take those same garbagey arguments
and establish them to prioritize anybody
there are differences
there are differences here's the way
that we can frame these differences
as a burden that needs to be eradicated
or
frankly here's the way so i'm just you
know the insane proposal to allow men to
retire earlier in order to you know
pursue an equitable outcome with regard
to post-retirement years
um is just trying to make the burden
you know the burden show up in the other
column like we can play this game all we
want right
uh and it's it doesn't make it any more
humane or reasonable
right no and the irony of it right is if
you did play this game
right if you really began to remake
civilization as we are doing based on
these nonsense
uh conclusions that exist in isolation
and you know
steadfastly ignore the thing that would
be on the other side of it if you just
simply uninvented all of the
counter-intuitive
stuff that makes civilization work and
you employed it
you would create all of the failures
that are so intolerable and you would
end up reinventing it
on the other side right i mean if you
survive to do it
right the danger is of course that by
hobbling ourselves we don't exist in a
vacuum
and we can't afford to go insane for 20
years
with you know china hovering
outside looking to to poach uh you know
opportunity or whatever um so we don't
get the
uh we don't get that luxury but were we
to do it
effectively it would be like a lesson in
why that counterintuitive stuff is so
important and
you know you can almost imagine the
reinvention of all of it and
you know how everybody would suddenly be
aware
of the importance of these things and
really it's like can we just skip to
that part
can we skip to the part where we remind
ourselves why these things are so
important
and why ultimately you cannot do better
than for example
a colorblind society you cannot do
better than a meritocracy in which
people have equal access and i'm not
saying that that's what we have
but i am saying in terms of a goal
that's it yeah you will not exceed it
right so
um yeah we're yeah we've got some system
that has the potential to be functional
and
you know how functional it is and where
we are in the process is what
the good faith people are disagreeing on
and we're going to get push here push
there a little bit of push
um but we are being asked to say nope
we're going all the way over here right
and that's because we've been
all the way over here in the past you
know like in 1950s alabama
and uh before the civil war and you know
all of these things
and you know this kind of arc in society
which we're going from extreme to
extreme
does not leave a society after very many
swings of that pendulum whereas a
relatively tight swing with adjustments
uh with the ability for constant
pushback against um
a trend towards extremism on any side
can't allow for progress and history
suggests that it does do exactly that
yeah and you know in some sense you can
reduce the entire thing
to a battle between um
those who wish to fix what's wrong
with the system and all reasonable
people recognize that it doesn't
reach that which it aspires to do but
it's a battle between the people who
want to fix what's wrong
and those who want to uninvent it on the
basis of what is claimed to be wrong
and the fact is the people who want to
uninvent it don't know what they're
talking about
they they can't tell you where we're
headed they can't tell you how we would
get there
and they don't appear to have even the
basic skills to analyze
you know where you need a
counter-intuitive conclusion and we just
don't have time for them to learn it by
destroying what we've got and
having to rediscover it all yeah
well there's one more thing that i
thought we might say something about but
maybe it's
it's not worth not worth going there um
do anything about this story
uh i think so i i'm not wearing my
glasses so i can't quite see it but
we're not going to go there then
okay um what else do you do you have
yeah we've got one more
thing i wanted to talk a little bit
about the podcast that i did
with gert vandenbush and what has
befallen it over
in facebook space um before you do that
let me say that um
i i have i have listened to part of it i
intend to listen to all of it
um and that i have seen a request for us
to discuss some of what
you talk about there and we're just not
prepared to do that yet yeah we're not
going to
uh revisit we may not we may not do it
at all but the content but let's just uh
catch people up on what we're talking
about so i released a podcast with
garrett
vandenbush who is
by training he is a
doctor of veterinary medicine uh he's
also
got a professional academic experience
in
vaccine creation and immunology in any
case
um he made quite a stir by releasing
an argument that the current vaccine
campaign
was in danger of creating uh escape
mutants that could make the pandemic
far worse rather than better and i had
him on the podcast and
i made a decision to
attempt to make the underlying
immunobiology
clear in this podcast so that people
could evaluate his argument the fact of
his argument created quite a stir but i
wanted people to understand
why he's making the argument what the
scientific claim is based on so that
they could then compare it
to alternative claims he really treated
it like a classroom you really
you gave a primer on immunobiology
yeah and i think you know i wasn't sure
about that decision but i think it
worked
quite well and lots of people had lots
of feedback from people who
appreciated being able to to look into
the the underlying questions
in any case i wasn't sure what would
happen to it on youtube
youtube has i think left it intact
uh and it has done uh well on youtube
facebook on the other hand um has taken
to a pending a warning to anybody who
attempts to post it and
clearly based on the number of people
who end up liking it they are obscuring
it from almost everyone
and the actually zach do you want to put
up the uh
warning that they have okay so this is
the warning that you get
um if you attempt to post my podcast and
i need to read it so that people who are
listening trying to see
yeah if you would this is zachary
our producer son it says from
independent fact checkers
uh about this notice independent fact
checkers say this information is
is missing context and could mislead
people learn more about how facebook
works with independent fact structures
uh to stop the spread of false
information
so um if you click through on
the what says fact check
uh mass vaccinations and covet 19
pandemic does not dot dot dot if you
click through on that that can you show
the site
uh so it goes to a independent
quote-unquote independent fact-checking
site
yep um
so okay so i guess you can see it here
now um
what this is is this lead stories
site having supposedly fact-checked
uh vandenbush's argument and deploying
counter arguments and facebook has
decided to declare that this site
is objective and in fact the url for
this
declares uh this
declares what vandenbush has advanced as
a hoax
which is preposterous i must tell you as
i said in my podcast so i don't i've
never
i don't know anything about the site
this is the first time i've ever seen it
would we
and uh all i can say is that facebook is
using this as an official source and if
you scroll down
scroll down through it keep going keep
going keep going
there you go look they've got a click
bait video that claims to debunk
garrett vandenbush's argument i have
watched this video now the video makes
some interesting arguments
right they are in no way
higher quality than what garrett is
deploying
right in effect what facebook has done
is it has taken
counter arguments and decided that they
are correct because they go in the
direction
of something facebook wants to claim
which is that these
vaccines are safe this goes right to the
point we were making previously where
well so just there's two distinct points
the vaccines are safe
in isolation and it is safe to widely
vaccinate
during a pandemic those are two because
as i understand it gert
actually thinks that um under the right
conditions in fact the thought
experiment that you provide is if if
code had been restricted to eurasia
um and north america for instance north
and south america were yet unexposed to
cove but mass vaccination
of exactly these vaccines in north and
south america right now would be safe by
his estimation
right so my
point is that what facebook is doing is
it is deciding
to find are there any experts
or people that we can claim our experts
who disagree with this
and then if there are which there always
will be then we are going to declare
them right and therefore declare this
other thing
not only incorrect but a hoax right
because that's what the url says it's a
hoax
which is nonsense and so it's a little
hard for me to know even where to start
with this
hoax is a strange new accusation too i
mean obviously there have been
charges of hoaxiness forever but um
it feels to me like that's rising in
power as an accusation that gets leveled
um so you know the epithets racist
transphobe anti-vaxxer
but hoax is like next level fake news
like maybe gear doesn't even exist maybe
he doesn't really believe this maybe
he's not really
you know like what what i feel like hoax
is being the term hoax is being
weaponized
here in a new way as well it's being
weaponized and i think that the purpose
of it
is that to the extent that you can do
anything that
invokes the idea of hoax right then
what you are effectively doing is saying
if you listen to
in this case garrett vandenbush and he
seems to make sense to you
that's because you're being taken right
so
it is a very different style of argument
than
this is incorrect because which we can
evaluate
in the case of the claim of hoax what
they're effectively doing
is saying that to the extent that you
think you have evaluated it you're a
sucker
right and so what that will cause is
anybody who sees the claim
that something is a hoax especially
coming through something as
you know big and important as facebook
will simply not get anywhere near it
because they don't want to be a sucker
we know you're busy we've saved you some
time here you don't need to go there at
all
right but here's my point this podcast
and i think with yours with garrett mine
with gary
our listeners should seek it out and
they should listen to it
and what you will hear are two people
who have
relevant expertise and insight having a
discussion in which they bend over
backwards to make
clear why the logic is what it is
right there's nothing hoaxy about this
could it be wrong sure
now i'm very careful in it to say i
don't know whether garrett is right
but i do know that he is making sense
right that is something i am in a
position to evaluate he is making sense
so what do you do with the fact of
facebook deciding
to simply search for some
claimed expert that disagrees with this
and then decide oh because there's an
expert who disagrees
this is now uh missing context or it's a
hoax or
it's uh incorrect or whatever their
conclusion is the point is that's
nonsense that's not how analysis
functions that's not how we discover
what is true and of course
we are again in the position where if we
played this game long enough and we did
enough
harm by allowing facebook to decide you
know
how facts are made or whatever it is
then we would
ultimately discover that we needed to
liberate people to have
arguments in which they disagree and the
medium through which they are
disagreeing does not intervene and
declare these people right and those
people
unforgivable and whatever it is we would
rediscover the need for things like
universities and salons and
freedom to advance counter-intuitive
claims and not suffer a social penalty
for it these are the things that we
would rediscover
if we ran this experiment to its logical
conclusion
and we're not going to get a chance to
because what we are in effect doing
is signing over our sense-making
capacity
to entities like facebook that don't
have
the basis to make these kinds of
decisions right these aren't
biologists and frankly as a biologist i
can say this is difficult material
right it's a struggle no matter who you
are no matter how much you know
nobody knows enough to say this is true
and that is false
right it has to unfold in the form of a
discussion in which arguments
are advanced and then they are honed as
a result of
uh counter arguments and then we
ultimately discover what our best
guess is to what's going to happen in
this case is and
um the idea that facebook thinks
otherwise is uh
frankly insane and all i can say is
get over your goddamn cells you aren't
that smart you aren't that well informed
and you're going to have to let the
adults talk
all right i'm off my soapbox
good not good that you're off it but uh
that was good i'm off it for now i'm
keeping the soapbox in case i gotta get
back up there and say some other stuff
you know i use it sometimes i i yeah i
do
i do you know that i know that i know
how to use the soapbox
when i said do you know that i use it
sometimes oh
sure yeah okay sorry um
thumbnail for this week thumbnail for
this week hey zach do you want to um
put up those uh so i did some uh
uh yeah just any order will do
all right that someone on uh
twitter thought that that that is
awesome but we didn't talk about that
this week we talked about that last week
what's going on here for the people just
listening this is the mother coyote
howling at you and me who are standing
next to the den where her
two kits are housed and hoping to drive
us
off so that she can turns out move them
what she did and last week we showed
um some video of her grabbing one of the
kits and
running off to wherever her new den
might
be i mean that is a beautiful photograph
but i think a lot of people wanted an
update this week and we haven't provided
one and especially that given that we
can't really use this as a thumbnail
okay this episode we will not use this
as a thumbnail
um perhaps we can promise
that we will give an update next week
sure sure i must say
the reason that showed up here was that
i was going through
the camera uh the pictures on the camera
and discovered that i had gotten
i didn't have any idea that i had
captured that image but it's beautiful
um all right here we have
uh a um well officially it's a great
blue hair and i would say it's a pretty
good
blue heron down at the uh the oaks
bottom
wildlife refuge
this i thought this was amazing um
this it turns out i am essentially
certain
is a golden eagle well we'll certainly
hear from people
if anyone thinks it's not yeah but uh i
believe i looked at that
picture close up and that was my best
guess but i'm like
totally good with the raptors so yeah
it's a it's a very very large animal
it's clearly not a bald eagle
yeah i think it almost has to be a
golden eagle um
but anyway beautiful creature um i did
none of the
correction of the photograph i should
have done but anyway there it is a
gorgeous creature that's uh
right here in in portland
golden eagle could be our um you know
you know could be our thumbnail for this
week working
towards a
an excellent future and you know it's
not it's not our national bird but it's
closely related yeah it's a it's a it's
a good and honorable bird
all right here we have a nutria uh i got
quite close to down at oak's bottom this
is uh an invasive
semi-aquatic rodent that we've talked
about a little bit
um and there he is eyeing me
suspiciously
and here he is swimming
uh in front of a mallard that's
definitely a nutrient
yep okay well we'll find out if it's not
but uh the three possibilities are
like it looked beaverish from here no
i'm not looking that i can't see
the tail was all wrong but they do look
very similar when they're swimming
okay next one now this one this is no
thumbnail but i want help on this one
so there's an interesting phenomenon i
think it's a crocodile
it's an interesting phenomenon down at
this wildlife refuge can you show it on
the big screen zach
thank you the wildlife refuge has a
rather large beaver pond as the central
water feature and as i was
sidling up to a snag
getting that picture of the great blue
heron
i was effectively had water on three
sides of me
and it was uh in the evening during the
golden hour
and these fish were engaging in this
flopping behavior which actually when
you and i and toby were down at the
refuge we saw this flopping behavior but
there was something else going on here
which was
i'm standing with these fish around me
and the flopping behavior actually at
some moments appears to be coordinated
right so i would guess i was just going
to say you know how um
in some uh populations of terceops of
dolphins
uh they will group hunt fish and cycle
and circle them into
tight coils before they go in for the
kill so maybe you were a target
i was they were hunting me um that's
possible i won't rule it out
um but anyway what i was watching was
every so often
a bunch of them would seem to startle
simultaneously so there'd be three or
four fish in different places and then
they would suddenly all
create a stir and i'm
certainly someone who is an expert uh
either an ichthyologist or an angler
is going to know what creature this is
uh obviously
uh freshwater beaver pond um it has a
connection from marshland to the
willamette i think
say again the chat thinks it's likely to
be a carp oh i find that unlikely
but a lot of the chat thinks that if
it's a carp then somebody must have put
it there right that's quite possible
yeah all right well that's interesting
and it's even possible i suppose
that given that this is a managed
wildland that a carp has been put in for
some purpose
like controlling mosquitoes or i don't
know what
um but anyway it didn't strike me as any
animal that i uh recognize that's a
large animal i should point out that
animal is probably
yeah why don't you put it in like a
quarter for scale foot and a half like i
did it just sank
[Laughter]
um yeah well i mean i tried that's why
they were startling you kept hitting
them with quarters that's it
they thought it was a drinking game um
all right so i guess that's it in terms
of uh
photographs for this week um cool okay
well
um that's it for us for this week for
those of you listening we're going to
take a 15-minute break then be back with
our live q a
as is our want answering questions you
have posed during this super chat
uh this hour and next uh once again
tomorrow at 11 a.m pacific
is our monthly two-hour q a for patrons
um please consider joining us there
brett also has conversations at his
patreon every month
and the first one they're always on the
first saturday and sunday of the month
so the first one will be taking place
right before
our live stream next saturday uh send
any questions you have to
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com uh you can we are we are maybe
moving forward on getting some new
merchandise available but we do have
some good stuff
at store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and our clips channel um is
is just producing stuff at a terrific
terrific rate
and you almost boxed yourself in at a
terrific clip
and then you said right and i just
thought very professionally done
um as is um the work that dave um
who who is um has created and is
managing and has produced some of the
clips for that channel
um he's doing terrific work so consider
um subscribing both to that and to this
channel
liking um excuse me commenting for the
algorithm
um you know joining us at our patreons
on social media if you like and make
sure to be good
be good to the people whom you love and
eat good food and get outside
all right be well everyone uh we'll see
you shortly
you